ja das generationen manifest immer mehr
unterzeichnen wir sind jetzt wurde das
interview machen bei 25.000 du hast
angefangen was einer ersten warum weil
ich es mag wenn man bestimmten leuten
die einfach nicht aus ihrem
schneckenhaus heraus kommen in diesem
fall halt unsere spitzenpolitiker mal
ein bisschen will endlich die pistole
auf die brust drückt also wirklich wenn
du einmal jemand daher kommt und sagt
pass mal auf
wir stehen kurz vor einer wahl wir haben
hier ein paar punkte unterzeichnet das
zeigt den leuten dass ihr will insight
für die kommende und vor allen dingen
die darauf kommende generationen zu
handeln und zwar so zielgerichtet nach
diesen punkten das man halt nicht immer
weiter deutschland in den dreck
wirtschaftet in den ruinen irgendwie
rein wirtschaften sondern dass man mal
sagt pass mal auf leute in 100 jahren
gibt es immer noch menschen söhne
töchter enkel und so weiter hier in
deutschland die vernünftig auf dieser
welt leben wollen und vernünftig in
diesem land leben wollen deswegen finde
ich einige dieser punkte in diesem
generationen manifest unfassbar gut und
finde dass es das verdient hat wirklich
dass das nach außen getragen wird auf
den frühling dass man auch die leute
erreicht die davon direkt betroffen sind
klar nicht jeder ist 18 und darf das
ding unterschreiben aber auch jeder der
13 14 15 jahre alt es interessiert sich
mit hoher wahrscheinlichkeit dafür und
sollte sich auch dafür interessieren für
dich und vor allem ist ja nicht nur
lippenbekenntnis sondern man kann ja
wirklich die politik damit beeinflussen
das hat sich jetzt gezeigt die ersten
werden darauf aufmerksam übrigens hier
unten der link auch im video ihr könnt
darauf klickt euch durch lesen
unterzeichnen
wir können wirklich die politik damit
beeinflussen was ist was ist dein
eindruck warum das bei den politikern so
ist wie du es beschrieben als sind eben
einfach in ihrem alltagstrott so
gefangen dass sie nicht mehr politik
gestalten können oder was muss sich da
ändern
ändern muss ich da eine ganze menge in
diesem falle finde ich sehr interessant
dass die politiker selbst wirklich etwas
unterschreiben sollen was dann so so
vertrags ähnlich quasi situiert ist was
wir bei den dingen was ich einfach
nochmal betonen will wichtig war wo ich
auch im vorfeld viel dazu recherchiert
hat ist dass es auf gar keinen fall
irgendwie partei gerichtet ist ich
wollte
wenn ich schon was unterstütze was
politisch ist nicht eingreifen in
irgendeine partei ich wurde nicht
irgendeine partei bevorzugen oder
irgendwas war davon bin ich überhaupt
kein freund aber das ding zwingt halt
leute konkret wenn sie unterschreiben
was zu tun und in diesem fall ist es so
dass ich finde dass die politik in
deutschland sehr diesen demokratischen
gedanken denen sie erhebt selbst
torpediert und zwar insofern dass vela
es hinnehmen dass politiker lügen weil
aber auch niemand der die wahrheit sagen
würde zum beispiel ja deutschland ist
zurzeit ziemlich wir haben den karren
ziemlich in dreck gefahren
wir müssen jetzt erst mal gucken dass
wir da wieder rauskommen und können halt
nicht 1000 neue schulen und kitas bauen
und so weiter und so fort weil die kohle
nicht da ist das darf aber keiner sagen
er wird ja nicht gewählt deswegen nehmen
die wähler belogen zu werden und
unterscheiden dann nur noch in die wahl
des kleineren übels und das ist was ich
allerdings finde dass in einer
demokratie so nicht geht und in diesem
fall gibt es ein paar punkte wo jemand
sagt ja ich verpflichte mich und meine
partei dazu nach diesen punkten zu
agieren
ich denke mal dass das wirklich einfluss
haben könnte nicht nur auf das weiß ich
jetzt beispielsweise in wahlergebnis
sondern auch vielleicht auch so
innerparteiliches denken wenn schon
jemand irgendwas zu sagen hat er
unterschreibt das heißt die idee
dahinter ist nicht das nur wähler dort
unterzeichnen sondern dass auch später
eben die politiker gegenzeichnung sagen
ich verpflichte mich dazu weil ich
glaube es gibt auch kein ziehen in dem
ganzen manifest als irgendein
parteiprogramm widerspricht eigentlich
können sie alle politiker unterschreiben
aber sie tun es nicht
sie handeln nicht danach interessant ist
auch dass dieses manifest der
veröffentlicht wurde auch in einer
großen tageszeitung und das dass dieses
manifest auch bereits einzelnen
politikern zu gekommen ist also man hat
den zukommen lassen und m
es wird gekonnt weg ignoriert ist ja ne
ist eine sehr beliebte strategie in
deutschland sachen totzuschweigen bei
diesem ding ist tatsächlich so dass die
dass die dass die pr einfach wie ich
persönlich finde so schlecht war dass
ich persönlich hatte davon noch gar
nichts mitbekommen
bis ich dann mal den kontakt quasi
aufgenommen hatte und das so für mich
entdeckt habe und mir gedacht hat das
muss man mal irgendwo jemanden zeigen
und dann bietet sich youtube gerade bei
dem was ich in den news und so mache
natürlich dementsprechend gut dafür an
und ich hoffe halt einfach mal dass das
ein bisschen aufrüttelt und wenn wir es
halt wirklich schaffen oder bzw wenn das
generationen manifest es schafft dass so
viele leute wie geplant als 100.000
leute unterzeichnen dann kann man das
nicht mehr ignorieren und das könnte
wirklich unsere politik beeinflussen
könnte weil die idee was ich auch schon
gesagt hast aber das finde ich
wahnsinnig wichtig ist die
unterschreiben das dann und die können
nicht wie bei was andere sei ja das
haben wir ja nicht gewusst das geld ist
ja gar nicht da als hätte das eine nicht
gewusst sondern sie haben es
unterschrieben sie sind ein pakt
eingegangen und ein wahnsinnig wichtiger
weil das was im moment gemacht wird das
ist ja alles auf kosten der jungen
generation und zwar nicht nur von euch
sondern auch der nächsten jetzt ein 23
jahre alt sind
das kann sich irgendwann keiner mehr
leisten richtig was ich allerdings da
wirklich so wichtig finde ist das was
was man auch verstehen muss ist dass das
nicht die politiker unterzeichnen nicht
irgendwas was ich ein paar ein paar
schlaue köpfe oder ein paar menschen aus
den medien oder irgendwie ausgedacht
haben die politiker unterschreiben dann
was wofür hoffentlich 100.000 menschen
gegen gezeichnet haben und sich das auch
wünschen so sagen wir mal hoffentlich
mindestens 100.000 mal sehen und das ist
halt so ein ding da verspricht man dann
nicht nur irgendwie medienwirksam oder
weil es gerade geheizt wird oder sonst
irgendwie was jemandem das ist nicht wie
so ein wahlprogramm wo man halt sagte
wir machen jetzt alles geil und
der klang her gut aber gucken wir
erstmal was war wirklich machen sondern
das ist ein ding das wollen so unfassbar
viele leute und so unfassbar viele leute
jetzt schon fast 30.000 dass das
durchgesetzt wird die da sich dann
möglich herauszufinden bei sachen die so
konkret sind das wird richtig schwer
und deswegen glaube ich aber auch ist
dieses pistole auf die brust setzen so
wichtig mit diesen vielen unterschriften
weil momentan weigern sie sicher sehr
gekonnt da eine unterschrift drunter zu
setzen und es ist das darf nicht
vergessen einmalige chance jetzt jetzt
in die bundestagswahlen in den nächsten
vier jahren wird man keinen dazu kriegen
da irgendwas zu tun
jetzt haben wir die chance zu sagen
unterschreibt jetzt und dann können wir
die nächsten vier jahre da ich auf die
finger gucken die nächste chance es erst
in vier jahren und dann ist ja wieder so
viel falsch gemacht also ich finde
unterschreiben und dass wir die 100000
hinkriegen finde ich fantastisch und
dann gucken wir mal was here you tube
alles bewegen kann und die leute die da
drauf aktiv sind vielen dank und bis
dann bleibt dran